і я дуже вдячна пані міністр ванці за це
розуміння Наскільки нам важливо зберегти
інтелектуальний потенціал України в
Україні і запобігти цьому вимуванню
інтелекту з України і найкращий рецепт
для цього - це широка участь України в
міжнародних програмах
ее Україна ратифікувала свою участь в
горизонті 2020 і сьогодні може бути
повноцінним партнером для таких проектів
але очевидно Ми вчимося Ми вчимося
писати правильно аплікації шукати
партнерів і для нас важливий досвід
німецьких колег і ми маємо е великий
досвід співпраці з 97го року тому що в
нас реалізовано Майже 300 білатеральних
проектів до цього часу в різних
сферах і і ці напрямки співпраці дуже
дуже різноманітні дуже важливі для нас